You know,
my entire schooling and all my professors were,
each one of them was,
I would say we're radically left.
I don't think I had a central professor.
All my supervisors and colleagues have been very strong leftist,
social justice warrior types of radical feminists.
And I always say to people that it astonishes me when,
um,
that Laurie a video came out and those professors called showing your video
quote Hitler.
Like I was absolutely astonished because out of every professor I've ever had,
almost every person I've ever met.
And these are very leftist people who clean compassion.
You have taken the strongest stance that of everyone I've ever met on atrocities
of the 20th century Nazi Germany,
uh,
Stalin's regime.
Um,
what happened in the Soviet Union.
You are always warning people about the dangers of that path.
You are the one that writes about,
it,
speaks about it,
talks about it,
tweets about it,
emails about it,
and yet you were referred to,
um,
and compared to when most evil people in human history.
And,
um,
of course,
Einstein.
But I'm wondering your feelings around that.
Well at some point the accusations gets so absurd that it's just surreal.
Yeah.
You can't even take it personally because it's so crazy.
I mean,
I've spent a lot of time talking to my students about and on videos about
Stalin,
but equal amounts of time talking about the Holocaust and Nazi Germany and
taking it apart and trying to indicate to people how lapses in personal
responsibility paved the road for four totalitarian atrocity essentially.
And yeah,
it's really amazing to have done all that work.
And then to be subject to that kind of,
what would you call it?
Well,
character assassination,
and it's even more amusing with,
well the Wilford,
but what I've learned over the last year,
at least in part Serena,
is that to be patient with this sort of thing,
because what's happened so far is every time I've been attacked,
the attackers in validate themselves.
You know,
I feel like I'm in a judo like position because I think it's in judo where your
attackers momentum against themselves,
you just roll with the punches,
you know?
And that's worked out incredibly well.
Wilfred Laurier is handling the Lindsay Shepherd affair so badly that you
couldn't script it worse.
I was watching the agenda.
I don't know.
I think you must have seen that episode where they had,
uh,
Janice Stein.
Yeah.
Professor Walcott.
And um,
of course your name came up and I was,
I was really hoping you were there to give your position,
but I found
I'm going on the agenda in January.
That's great.
That's that they're going to grill me,
they're going to roast me over the coals.
So,
which is a good thing I think.
Yeah.
I was really surprised at the comment by Professor Walcott when he said,
you're not an expert and you're not qualified to comment on the issues of gender
or gender and sexual identities,
et cetera.
But yet he is a black man,
is the director of the women's programs.
So how is he qualified to be in that position as a male?
I don't understand that.
I don't understand that inconsistent way of thinking.
Well,
I wouldn't,
first of all,
I wouldn't say that consistency is the hallmark of postmodern thinking.
It's whatever argument goes at the time.
And Yeah,
I thought w Walcott's performance on the agenda was absolutely reprehensible as
well as his comments about the white Tas who were,
who were always oppressing,
you know,
professors of color to use those horrible,
that horrible phrase ology that the radical left seems to insist upon.
You know,
he described the University of Toronto was a white supremacist organization,
I think four times failing to recognize entirely that he's hired in a very,
let's call it the privileged position at that university,
and the mere fact of his positioning is indication for the fall.
So of his claims.
Any sense would see
all you have to do is pick any building at u of t downtown and just go walk
through the hallways.
Anybody that suggests that it's a white supremacist institution is,
is not thinking clearly.
They're out of there.
Their
mind.
I was,
I was just at the university yesterday and I drove by a bunch of students who
were standing outside waiting to take their exams and if anything,
the Caucasian kids were in the minority.
It's really true at the University of Toronto and increasingly true and very
rapidly,
increasingly true.
Certainly women or men are in the minority already out by a large margin,
a dangerously large margin in my estimation,
but the idea that that that you could call it the University of Toronto,
which I think you'd have to think,
I really believe this,
that you'd be hard pressed to go anywhere in the world and find an organization.
It's actually done a better job of integrating such a tremendously diverse range
of people into a functioning unit in the University of Toronto.
I think you could just say some positive things about u of t two last year they
wrote me a couple of letters asking me to keep my mouth shut basically,
and which I think was a strategic error,
but they did host the debate afterwards,
which was a good thing.
And I would also say that the University of Toronto seems to have come down
pretty firmly on the side of free speech since then.
And I also feel that my position there as a professor is in no danger
whatsoever,
despite the fact that,
you know,
every couple of months,
200 of the usual usual suspects find it necessary to write a petition claiming
that I've done something reprehensible and that the university should fire me.
But there's no,
I don't feel that my position is in danger there at all.
So.